Gegen Plenum.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja, tatsächlich war es so, dass wir eben diese Struktur hatten. Also wie die meisten Spiele Spielregeln hatten, haben und einen Spielverlauf hatte There is no Game, hat sich quasi daran orientiert. Und in diesem Verlauf über die vier Tage hinweg war aber auch angedacht im Spielnarrativ, dass sich die Spielstruktur am Ende selbst abschafft. Dieses Ding, das There is no Game macht, ist am Ende nicht mehr da. Denn für uns war auch There is no Game eben kein Spiel, sondern ein Anfang von etwas. Und die Struktur, die wir da als Hilfsstruktur geschaffen haben, existiert ja de facto nach diesen vier Tagen, nach dem Kongressende auch nicht mehr. Und danach sind die Menschen quasi auf sich selbst gestellt. Also die Phase des Kongresses quasi als Tutorial, um dann in die echte Welt rauszugehen und sich selbst zu organisieren, war auch in diesem Narrativ drin. Denn ich glaube, niemand oder nie ein Mensch von uns möchte, dass sich das, dass eine AI oder irgendwas sich irgendwie über uns stellt und unser aller Regen regelt. Was die Hackability quasi eines solchen Ereignisses angeht, haben wir tatsächlich auch immer versucht, das ein bisschen mitzudecken und eigentlich zu fördern. Also gerade dadurch, dass kein Spiel ja generellen Spielprinzipien zuwidergelaufen ist, dass du also nicht mit deiner Bande gegen andere Bande gespielt hast, hast du, wenn du die Lösung zu einer Aufgabe verraten hast, eigentlich das Spiel nicht gebremst. Also wenn du anderen geholfen hast, oder wenn du gecheatet hast in diesem Sinne, weil du das Passwort anderen erzählst, sondern eigentlich vorangetrieben. Also es war quasi von uns ein Stück weit gewünscht und mitgedacht, dass die Leute sich dessen ermächtigen und sich gefühlt darüber hinwegsetzen, wie die Dinge laufen. Und das ist dann auch so weit gegangen, dass die Spielenden eine eigene Wiki-Seite angelegt haben, darüber, welche Passwörter wo sind und was genau sie erlebt haben und so untereinander angefangen haben auszutauschen, was passiert ist. Und das ging quasi über unsere Erwartungen auch hinaus, muss ich dazu sagen.
Also Leute, die versucht haben, andere Leute auszustechen oder schneller zu sein oder erst oder was auch immer?
Also nicht, dass wir es mitbekommen hätten. Und ich wollte quasi noch dazu ergänzen, dass quasi ja das System, was wir angelegt haben, sogar so weit gegangen ist, dass das System ja selbst so eine Art Cheat am dritten Tag hatte. Weil es gab zum Beispiel am dritten Tag immer nur das gleiche Passwort. Also was immer MROFSKROF war. Und dadurch war es eigentlich, ist es ad absurdum geführt worden, das System. Du musstest die Quest nicht lösen, um quasi weiterspielen zu können. Weil du konntest auch eigentlich, und das haben auch manche Banden gemacht, die haben hintereinander immer wieder das Passwort eingegeben und haben dann immer wieder eine neue Quest ausgespuckt bekommen. Aber es ging quasi ja nicht darum, immer dieser einen linearen Queststruktur zu folgen, sondern eben auch in Kontakt zu treten mit anderen.
Was wir tatsächlich auch zwischendurch geplant haben, ist, dass wir an Tag drei die Quest rausgeben, dass alle Banden sich selber Quests ausdenken und zu uns in unser lustiges Backoffice gehen, wo das Spielmonitoring die ganze Zeit stattgefunden hat und wir quasi relativ live die Storylines zusammenklicken konnten, die wir neuen Banden gegeben haben. Und selber da reingehen, selber dieses System füttern und für neue Banden wiederum Storylines bauen. Was wir dann uns aber tatsächlich aus Kräfte, also kräftetechnisch und organisatorisch nicht getraut haben zu machen, weil wir so wenig wussten, wie es an Tag 3 sein wird. Was es aber auch gab, es gab eben diese linearen Storylines, die wir hatten und diese Quests hintereinander, sind natürlich ein ganz großer Teil der Erfahrung gewesen, sind aber spielmechanisch erstmal auch der Rahmen gewesen, der das Spiel überhaupt hat stattfinden lassen, was es nicht gab. Und es gab immer sogenannte Mainquests. Es gab zum Beispiel eine Quest, wo eine aktivistische Gruppe beim Kongress zu Gast war, die Video-Streaming-Unterstützung für ein politisches Projekt gesucht haben. Und da war einfach die Quest, findet die in dem Konferenzraum, den sie reserviert haben, und versucht sie mit dem Wok zusammenzubringen zum Beispiel. Da gab es kein Passwort für, keine Punkte für. Das ist einfach passiert und da haben wir am Ende ungefähr 30 Leute zwei Stunden mit denen über ihr Projekt gesprochen. So und das haben wir im Verlauf dieser vier Tage immer mehr provoziert. Es gab übergeordnet sozusagen, haben wir schon versucht damit zu arbeiten, dass die Leute eventuell am Anfang denken, dass es auf Konkurrenzprinzipien basiert und haben dann aber schnell das Narrativ so weiterentwickelt, dass es darum geht, dass diese Banden sich zusammenschließen und dass es am Ende eine große Bande gibt. Und insofern gibt es schon sozusagen gewisse Dramaturgien da drin, die wir natürlich vorgegeben haben, die wir knallhart an unserer Riesenwand im Gängeviertel vorgezeichnet und aufgezeichnet haben, wie sie passieren sollen und natürlich damit total viel vorgegeben haben. Am Ende haben wir das Narrativ so geschlossen, dass eben diese künstliche Intelligenz, die so ein bisschen angelehnt an so Dämon und Darknet von Suarez, das sind wir auf jeden Fall großer Fan von alle, sagt, okay, ich bin Anfang diesen Jahres aufgewacht, weil die Kacke so am Dampfen ist und bin hier gewesen, um zu testen, zu überprüfen, ob die Menschheit zur Kollaboration fähig ist. Ihr seid soweit, ihr seid bereit, ihr könnt jetzt anfangen, euch zu transformieren und diese Gesellschaft zu transformieren.
Aber das könnte ja zwei Dinge bedeuten, nämlich einerseits, wenn die Spieler nicht nur das Spiel nicht spielen, sondern auch euren Gedanken und Zielen folgen, fangen sie an der Stelle an, selber das Spiel nicht zu spielen. Oder der Abspann kommt. Also weil, man hat eine Geschichte und dann gibt es das große Ding und dann ja, Feuerwerk, wir sind bereit, Erde gerettet.
Vielleicht ein kleiner Zeitpunkt, eine kleine Hörerinnenfrage. Liebe Menschen da draußen, liebe Nichtspielenden, wenn ihr mitkriegt oder wisst, wo kein Spiel stattfindet, wo Dinge seitdem entstanden sind, lasst es uns wissen. Weil wir haben tatsächlich erstmal einfach geschlafen, total lange geschlafen und haben jetzt, sind überhaupt noch nicht an einem Punkt, wo wir, es gab weder Abspann noch von uns ein forciertes Fortschreiten dieses Narrativs. Es gibt unterschiedliche Projekte, die über den Kongress hinausgehen. Das ist eine Sprache, die entwickelt wurde. Da kann Miko vielleicht noch was zu erzählen gleich. Das ist unter anderem auch ein soziales Netzwerk, was nebenbei noch entwickelt wurde zu diesem Spiel, was auch auf diesem Skillshare-Prinzip basiert. Genau, wo wir gerade weiter daran arbeiten. Das ist Talenet. Das ist ein soziales Netzwerk, wo du dich anmelden kannst, einträgst, was du kannst und dann Ideen eintragen kannst und sagen kannst, diese und diese und diese Fähigkeiten brauche ich, um diese Idee umzusetzen. Und die Fähigkeiten-Owner werden sozusagen benachrichtigt, wenn ihre Fähigkeit irgendwo gebraucht wird und können sich mit einem Projekt assoziieren.
Ist das dann noch ein Spiel oder ist das schon gedacht als...
Das ist kein Spiel. Das ist der Punkt. Es ist alles kein Spiel. Es ist die fucking Wahrheit. Es ist echt.
Also das ist auch... Also ich kann mir vorstellen, das Problem ist, man kann natürlich ganz oft sagen, da ist kein Spiel und das ist echt schon sowas und das hat ja aber immer so ein... Da bleibt der Rest von intellektueller Überhöhung eines Theaterstücks, das aufgeführt wird. Und ich frage mich, geht das dann wirklich in die echte Welt? Ich sag's in ganz großen Anführungszeichen, ganz ungern. Aber hat das wirklich diesen Effekt, dass man solange man in so einer Verklausellierung bleiben muss, dass wirklich sozusagen der Wunsch ist, wenn ich richtig verstehe, das soll in die Normalität gehen und Menschen befähigen, mehr und einfacher zu kooperieren?
Ja, zum einen das und zum anderen, wenn es vielleicht nicht den sofortigen Effekt hat, dass es sich quasi in die Realität ausbreitet, dann hat es zumindest den Effekt, dass es in dem Moment, wo es nicht stattgefunden hat, dass es in dem Moment einen Erfahrungsraum ermöglicht. Also die Erfahrung, über die wir schon gesprochen haben. Und das können ja Erfahrungen sein, die sich vielleicht abgrenzen von den Erfahrungen, die du in der normalen Gesellschaft machst. Und deswegen, finde ich, regt das ja dann vielleicht wieder an, wenn du draußen bist, vielleicht kein Spiel zu spielen, sondern aber darüber nachzudenken und nachzudenken, krass. Ich habe eine Erfahrung gemacht, die mir gezeigt hat, dass meine persönliche Fähigkeit von Wert ist, aber im Kontext mit anderen Menschen. Und dass, wenn wir uns zusammentun, wir total viel erreichen können und wenn wir unzufrieden sind, zum Beispiel mit einer politischen Situation, dann können wir uns als Gruppe zusammentun. Und die Erfahrung, dass es funktioniert, habe ich gemacht, während quasi There is no Game. Weil da haben wir uns mit unterschiedlichen Fähigkeiten zusammengetan und konnten quasi eine Aufgabe lösen, die ich alleine nicht lösen konnte.
Da möchte ich vielleicht auch noch mal einhaken. Du hattest ja vorhin gefragt, kann man das überhaupt noch Spiel nennen, weil Spiel ja eigentlich konsequenzfrei ist. Und vielleicht könnte man deswegen ja genau sagen, ja dann ist es halt kein Spiel so. Aber ich glaube, dieser Erfahrungsraum ist so wahr. Und ich würde auch jetzt noch allen Menschen sagen, hey bildet Banden, gründet Kollektive, lasst euch darauf ein. Generiert Quests, generiert Aufträge an andere Leute, spielt mit ihnen.
Also was tatsächlich ganz konkret, zwar sozusagen ein bisschen hinter den Kulissen, aber sehr weit in die Realität reinreicht, ist das Team, was sich um dieses Projekt gebildet hat. Wo ich kurz sagen möchte, die Musik vorhin ist von Sleika, das haben wir nämlich nicht gesagt, der diese Musik geschrieben hat. Die ganzen Leute, die da zusammengekommen sind und das sind wirklich Menschen, die über sieben Ecken gehört haben, dass sie was machen. Und Sascha zum Beispiel, der dann geschrieben hat, ich beschäftige mich mit partizipativen Design, der da zugekommen ist und auf der Ebene mitgearbeitet. Diese ganzen Leute, die da zusammengekommen sind, sind alle in einem Regenaustausch und so heiß auf weiter in dieser Konstellation zusammenarbeiten, weiter mit dieser offenen Haltung zusammenarbeiten, weiter Dinge schaffen, dass das allein sich sehr in die Realität ausgebreitet hat. Das ist für uns alle, auch wie Marcus gesagt hat, in Hamburg tatsächlich, weil da mehr von uns sind, noch ein bisschen präsenter. Aber das liegt immer noch wahnsinnig in der Luft und es ist so weit gegangen. Und ich genau nochmal gerne an alle da draußen, wir freuen uns zu hören, wie es sich in der Realität ausbreitet, wenn es das tut. Wir wissen das nicht.
Ich finde es tatsächlich eine seltene Gelegenheit, wo ich schade finde, dass wir jetzt keine ordentliche Call-In-Möglichkeit haben. Würde mich natürlich auch interessieren, weil was mich gerade frage, von dem was ihr sagt, klingt das sozusagen als Experiment und Phänomen ganz nett. Aber je länger ich darüber nachdenke, desto mehr denke ich, das passt aber auch sehr gut zum Kongress. Das passt ganz gut zu einer Hacker-Mentalität, wo man sagt, ich bin nicht unbedingt nur ein Individuum, ich bin auch eine Ansammlung von Skillsets. Das kann ich projektweise auch gerne kombinieren. Und dann ist wieder die Frage, ist die echte Welt tatsächlich die zwischen Nicht-Spiel und was diese Charaktere, die da nicht mitgespielt haben, sonst machen? Oder ist die Frage, wenn das einen reellen Effekt haben soll, müsste das dann nicht aus dieser Community raus eigentlich? Und geht das?
Na, der Kongress, das ist ja generell so eine Mitmachveranstaltung. Jeder kann sich einbringen. Das gibt dieses Engelsystem über zehn Prozent der Leute, der Besucher haben dort geengelt und mitgearbeitet. Jeder kann sich einbringen. Und das ist sozusagen auch die Message, die von diesen vier, fünf Tagen oder für viele, viele, viele Leute, es sind ja viel länger, die schon vorher da sind, aufbauen oder abbauen, im Prinzip mit nach Hause nehmen. Und wir haben halt sozusagen in diese Richtung noch mal ein bisschen gepusht oder noch mal eins draufgesetzt oder sozusagen diese ganze Sache noch mal ermöglicht, auf eine andere Art und Weise die Leute dazu zu bringen, halt mitzumachen. Was ich vorhin schon sagte, auf allen möglichen Arten und Weisen halt Content einbringen oder Software schreiben oder was alles passiert ist.
Ich glaube natürlich, dazu finde ich auch wichtig, dass für uns der Eintritt in diese ganze Kongress-Realität und Community, also für mich persönlich war der erste Kongress der totale Strukturorgasmus, weil ich aus diesen ganzen anderen Kollektiven und Räumen komme und dahin gekommen bin und gedacht hab, Wahnsinn, wie geil, dass hier alles funktioniert. Wie alle einfach so richtig simpel. Das einfach hochziehen und durchziehen. Und natürlich ist ein Teil dieser Utopie, die wir für uns formulieren, da dran auch gewachsen. Und natürlich war eine Idee davon auch, Leuten, die vielleicht nicht dahin kommen und sich als Hacker begreifen, das lustige Non-Coder-Problem, so ich komm dahin und ich denke, ich gehöre nicht dazu, weil ich es nicht kann, diese Leute zusammenzubringen. Und es sind eben so Sachen wie natürlich sind Leute, die vielleicht das erste Mal beim Kongress sind und sie nicht ihr Hardcore-Projekt da haben, die, die vielleicht eher spielen, die dann aber das Freifunkrätsel kriegen. Und dann halt erstmal einfach jemanden finden müssen und rausfinden müssen, okay, ah an diesen Tischen, ich kann dahin gehen, da sitzen Leute, ich kann mit denen sprechen, ich kann mir das erklären lassen, ich kann ihr nachfragen und da total reingezogen werden auch dadurch. Und was übergeordnet natürlich ist die Frage, dürfen wir dahin kommen, relativ von außen kommt und für diese Community so ein Projekt machen. Am Ende sind wir aber auch dahin gekommen, um Bescheid zu sagen. Um dieser ganzen Hacker-Community zu sagen, Leute, wir brauchen euch, wir brauchen diese ganzen einzelnen Skillsets und wir müssen zusammenarbeiten, weil es so geil ist, wenn wir das tun. Unser Team, als wir gesagt haben, wir wollen ganz viel Partizipation haben und dann Marcus und Clemens sich hingesetzt haben und eine Schnittstellen-Dokumentation geschrieben haben und uns erklärt haben, was das ist und uns erklärt haben, wie wir das wiederum an die Nerds teilweise schicken, wo wir jedes Wort in der E-Mail googeln mussten, weil wir überhaupt nicht verstanden haben, was die uns geschickt haben. Also wir haben alle so viel gelernt dabei und wir sind alle so an unsere Grenzen gekommen, auch wo ich auch nochmal gesagt habe, dieses Interdisziplinäre, was in diesem Team stattgefunden hat, dieses übergeordnete Zusammenarbeiten, das ist so challenging für uns alle gewesen und es ist so spannend gewesen und es ist so ermächtigend zu verstehen, wie andere Departments oder Communities funktionieren und irgendwie aber zu begreifen, dass diese Idee von ich hab eine Community eigentlich alle verbindet und dass wir das eben, ne, intersubkulturelles Community building ist auch so ein Schlagwort dafür gewesen. So, wir wollten mal hingehen und sagen Leute, lass mal jetzt anfangen zusammenzuarbeiten und mal gucken, ob alle sagen, okay geil, machen wir ja richtiger Zeitpunkt.
Gleichzeitig würde ich das auch nochmal auf einer übergeordneten politischen Ebene auch verstehen, dass es eben genau auch darum geht, diese Hackerinnen-Mentalität in das echte Leben rauszutragen. Eben so wie ich durch das Coden Räume verändere, also durch das Coden einen Raum verändere, ich setze neue Regeln in einem Programm und dann ändert sich quasi das Gesamtkonstrukt, kann ich das auch im Sozialen tun. Ich setze neue Regeln, ich setze mich mit Regeln auseinander, ich ändere die Regeln in kleinen sozialen Interaktionen und ich kann das üben und ich kann das eben auch im Alltag tun, indem ich quasi die Norm, eine fremde Person nicht anzusprechen, durchbrechen lerne. Oder eine eigene Regel mir setze, auf eine spielerische Art und Weise gesprochen, dass ich das jetzt eben tue. Und diesen Step quasi sehe ich mit There is no Game angespielt. Also dass man eben diese Mentalität, wie man Dinge ändert, wie man Dinge hackt, eben auch im Sozialen zu verstehen beginnt. Und da finde ich schon, dass es nicht nur darum geht, dass da andere Leute dazukommen sollten, sondern dass es quasi eben darum geht, dass auch diese Leute raustreten. Also es geht um dieses intersubkulturelle Community-Binding, was für ein Wort.
Wo wir vielleicht schon ganz normal sagen können, dass wir uns auf jeden Fall auch als Hackerinnen begreifen. Weil wir Social Hacking betreiben.
Was sind das Feedback? Oder bekommt ihr Feedback sozusagen? Oder habt ihr euch sozusagen so weit rausgenommen, dass es gar keine Ansprechpartnerinnen gibt und deswegen auch kein Feedback zu dem Projekt kommt?
Wir haben auf einer Ebene Feedback bekommen von Leuten, die teilweise im Team, also es gab Leute, die mit dem Team assoziiert waren und auch teilgenommen haben, die ein sehr starkes Feedback gegeben haben. Es gibt teilweise von so einzelnen Kontaktpersonen in der Community Feedback, was die uns weitergeben. Es ist aber immer noch so, dass wir relativ wenig gehört haben oder bekommen haben, was aber auch daran liegt, dass wir wenig Strukturen dafür zur Verfügung gestellt haben bzw. einfach echt ein bisschen untergetaucht sind vor Erschöpfung im Moment erst mal und gerade so aufwachen.
Wir freuen uns über Feedback und Kritik und alles.
Also während der Veranstaltung, also wir hatten ja sozusagen, wo der vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen, so auch technische Schnittstellen zur Verfügung gestellt, wo andere Leute im Prinzip ihre eigenen Projekte integrieren konnten. Was glaube ich viele Leute kennen ist ACAP, also All Colors are Beautiful, das ist so eine Lichtinstallation. Und die konnten dann halt einfach ein kleines Stück Software schreiben, was denn sozusagen mit unseren Schnittstellen gesprochen hat, dass wir, dass unsere Game Designer sozusagen oder unsere Leute, die den Content verwaltet haben, im Prinzip diese ACAP Wand mit ins Spiel einbauen konnten, in der Art, dass wenn Benutzer oder wenn sozusagen eine Bande eine Aufgabe gelöst hat, dass dann halt bestimmte Animationen auf so einer Wand abgelaufen sind. Von diesen Dingen gab es ganz viele auf dem Kongress. Und da kam viel Feedback von Leuten, die halt selber Software geschrieben haben, ihre eigenen LED-Matrixen oder Matrizen angebunden haben oder die Flipdot-Matrix und so weiter. Das war für die Leute natürlich das Stargate. Die fanden das natürlich cool. Plötzlich hatte sie ihr eigenes Projekt, wo sie vielleicht schon ein Jahr oder ein halbes Jahr oder wie auch immer daran arbeiten, plötzlich einen größeren Kontext bekommen. Oder sie wurden in ein Spiel eingebunden. Das ist ja immer toll, weil sie damit auch Teil des Spiels wohnen. Und auch Produzenten und nicht nur Konsumenten und so weiter. Also zumindest von dieser Seite kam auch viel Feedback.
Habt ihr, also die Idee, also ihr seid jetzt untergetaucht, vermute ich es damit auch, die Struktur, die ihr während des Kongresses betrieben habt, erstmal nicht mehr verfügbar gewesen. Und die war ja auch auf diesen Ort und diese Zeit erstmal beschränkt. Habt ihr jemals drüber nachgedacht, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise, keine Ahnung, in der Stadt oder so zu etablieren? Also quasi, dass man sagt, okay, es ist nicht der Kongress und es ist auch nicht dieser ganz enge, hohe Schlagzahl. Aber bevor wir euch wirklich in die komplette Selbstorganisation entlassen, machen wir das nochmal, keine Ahnung, mit einem langsameren Herzschlag in einem größeren Gebiet oder wie auch immer.
Da sind wir gerade so ein bisschen dran. Also deswegen haben wir drei, Miko, Katja und ich uns auch jetzt hier getroffen, weil ich in Berlin bin und die beiden in Hamburg, weil das so ein bisschen so auch die generelle Frage ist, wo geht das jetzt hin oder wie kann das weiterentwickelt werden? Also weil es natürlich auch viele Anfragen in dem Sinne, vielleicht ist das auch so ein bisschen nochmal in die Feedback-Richtung. Es gibt natürlich schon viele Anfragen, die in die Richtung gehen, kann There is no Game nochmal irgendwo stattfinden oder kann das nochmal irgendwo Teil eines Camps, eines Festivals sein? Und da fragen wir uns halt auch gerade, wie kann sich das weiterentwickeln? Weil für uns ist klar, There is no Game kann als There is no Game nicht mehr stattfinden.
Aber ist es nicht gleichzeitig super frustrierend und ein Kompliment? Also wenn gesagt wird, okay, diese Struktur, die ihr geschaffen habt, von der ihr nicht mehr wollt, dass sie existiert, könnt ihr die nochmal herbringen?
Ja, also ich glaube, es ist natürlich super, wenn uns Leute fragen und natürlich sind wir da doch immer so, oh geil und jetzt und wir fahren überall hin und sowieso und kein Halten mehr. Was aber einfach der Punkt ist, ist in diesem halben Jahr, in dem wir daran gearbeitet haben, dadurch, dass das so live war und dadurch, dass wir nicht wussten, was passiert, weil wir haben lange auch gewartet auf Quest-Einreichungen und dann haben wir plötzlich gemerkt, ah ok, jetzt haben sich die ganzen Assemblies angemeldet und plötzlich hagelte es E-Mails und wir haben überhaupt nicht mehr gepennt. Diese ganze Verantwortung, die wir auch hatten, damit, dass wir uns den Schuh angezogen haben, diese Struktur zu verwalten, ist too much gewesen. Und da ist einfach auch die Frage, was davon können wir wie zur Verfügung stellen, damit Dinge wie There is no Game passieren können, ohne dass wir so Jetset-mäßig von einem Ort zum nächsten fahren und das überall runterrattern, weil da haben wir überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Und es gibt garantiert viele geile Sachen, die andere Leute damit wiederum machen können. Und das, genau, es gibt natürlich diese Struktur natürlich noch. Es gibt, was wir auch überhaupt nicht erzählt haben, diese ganzen Keyholes, diese Schlüssellöcher, die man mit diesen USB-Schlüsseln schließen konnte, die gibt es ja. Es gibt auch Toto, die Software, die bei Markus liegt. Es gibt die ganzen Ideen, es gibt die ganzen Quests, es gibt ganz viele Sachen, die die Leute dafür gebaut haben. Und das ist die große Verantwortung, die wir gerade haben, wir drei, aber auch sozusagen dieses große Team, was sich jetzt am Samstag in Hamburg das erste Mal in einem Teil wieder treffen wird seit dem Kongress, wo wir einfach genau das fragen werden. So, okay, wo geht es denn jetzt hin? Was machen wir denn jetzt damit? Wir haben das angestoßen und haben, ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir im November irgendwann gesagt haben, wir können im Januar sozusagen mit Charmes Röte im Gesicht in der Ecke stehen, weil überhaupt nichts funktioniert hat. Oder im Bundestag sitzen. Und zwar alle zusammen. Also wir wussten gar nicht, was passiert. Genau. Obwohl wir diese Struktur so verwaltet haben, ist uns das genauso passiert, weil wir ganz lange gebastelt haben und dann haben wir auf Start gedrückt. Und dann ist das jetzt so passiert. Und das ist auch wieder eine Verantwortung, die auch alle Spielenden im Prinzip mithaben.
So let's did it. Dann mal sehen, was dabei noch rumkommt. Wir haben ja gleich noch eine halbe Stunde, die wir darüber reden können. Vorher haben wir noch eine kleine Musik, die kommt noch mal vom Anti-Hero-Album von Babel und heißt Mutants.
Take this thing on, dude.
Da sind wir wieder, glaube ich, hoffe ich, sind wir da wieder. Hallo.
Hallo.
Hallo. Im Chaosradio 232 und wir reden noch eine halbe Stunde über das Spiel, das nicht ist. Das könnte auch so ein deutscher Liedermacher Titel sein. Ist es aber nicht, sondern es gab einen, einen... Wow, ich hab gerade überlegt, wenn ich jetzt Kunstprojekt auf dem Chaos Communication Congress sage, seid ihr dann beleidigt?
Auf jeden Fall, keine Kunst. Kunst gildet nicht.
Kunst gildet nicht. Wir haben darüber geredet, dass ihr ein Projekt gemacht habt, was Leute dazu animieren sollen, mit anderen Leuten zu kooperieren, was über eine Struktur funktioniert, die spielerisch ist und Spiele zusammenfasst. Also quasi einzelne Spiele, einzelne Aufträge. Und die, die große Idee, der große Wunsch ist, dass das auch außerhalb funktioniert oder dass das immer funktioniert. Dass Menschen sich dazu motiviert fühlen, das in ihr Leben mitzunehmen. Und was ich mich jetzt gerade noch frage ist, inwieweit das geht. Es klang vorhin schon mal kurz an, dass das vielleicht das Mindset, also bei Leuten, die auf einen Kongress gehen, egal ob so sagen Tech-Hacker oder nicht, vielleicht gerade das Richtige ist, weil man geht in diese Veranstaltung, das ist im Prinzip auch wie ein Spiel. Die hatten ganz klares Anfang und Ende. Und ihr habt ja auch gesagt, was ihr damit verfolgt ist, dass man hat Angst fremde Leute anzusprechen. Und vielleicht ist es aber so, wenn du zum Kongress gehst, dann hast du auf jeden Fall schon mal den Willen, fremde Leute anzusprechen, du weißt nur nicht wie. Das heißt, man beantwortet diese Wie Frage durch There is no Game. Aber der Impuls ist auf jeden Fall schon mal da. Und ihr habt auch als Vergleich gebracht Demon von Zuras. Und da funktioniert es ja so, dass die Menschen alle in diesem System mitarbeiten, weil sie keine andere Wahl haben. Das ist das, was Perry Roden auch schon gemacht hat. Das Alien-Raumschiff landet und die Welt vereinigt sich gegen die Aliens und arbeitet zusammen. Und jetzt ist aber, wenn ihr das Spiel rausnimmt, aus dem Kongress mitnimmt in die Welt, es gibt ja wieder die, also wenn ihr mir nichts verschwiegen habt. Die Orange bedrohen, es gibt keinen äußeren Impuls, der die Leute dazu zwingt. Und wenn man jetzt nicht nur die Hacker-Community und den Umkreis auf dem Kongress kommt, sondern sozusagen die ganze Gesellschaft in der Gesellschaft zu beobachten, das ist sehr viel, ich bleibe bei mir, in meinem Haus, mit dem Zaun drum rum und will da gar nicht rausgehen. Also die Frage ist, wenn ihr There is no Game noch weiter bringen wollt als in diese Kreise, müsst ihr vielleicht nicht nur die Frage beantworten, wie spreche ich anderen an, sondern auch vorher noch dazu, also irgendwie diesen Impuls setzen, dass es überhaupt eine Notwendigkeit dafür ist. Seht ihr das auch als eure Aufgabe oder denkt ihr so, ok, wenn die Gesellschaft das nicht mehr leisten kann, dann ist es auch egal, dann reißen wir alles ab.
Also ich möchte dazu ganz kurz antworten auf diese Sache mit, es gibt keine Bedrohung, aber es gibt ja trotzdem Gründe und es gibt ja auch so viele große politische Ereignisse, die in Hamburg dieses Jahr stattfinden und there is no fusion, there is action. Also es wird außerhalb des Kongresses auftreten und keine Spiele und Möglichkeiten zur Kollaboration geben dieses Jahr, das mal so am Rande benannt. Und das andere ist, natürlich wissen wir, dass wir auf dem Kongress oder auch auf anderen Festivals in einem totalen Schutzraum uns bewegen und natürlich alle Leute sowieso per se schon mal eigentlich sich eh irgendwie anschnacken gegenseitig und genau im Zweifelsfall nur Tools dafür suchen. Und natürlich ist die Vorstellung, dass am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof stattfinden zu lassen. Eine Idee von Verantwortung, die wir haben, was wir machen wollen, das ist aber einfach auch ein anderes Level von Umsetzung, weil wir auf dem Kongress halt einen wahnsinnigen Support bekommen haben, das da umsetzen zu können und wie wir gerade in der Pause erzählt haben, wir den Kulturförderungsantrag There is no Project, There is no Game, dafür haben wir die Absage bekommen, als wir ins CCH eingezogen sind quasi. Es ist einfach schwieriger in der ganz realen Welt, solche Dinge in der Größe stattfinden zu lassen, ohne dass die Stadtreinigung hinter uns herfährt und die ganze Zeit alles wegmacht, was wir da hin tun.
Also was wollt ihr und was glaubt ihr, was würde realistisch passieren?
Also ich glaube, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Strategien. Also zum einen gibt es Strategien, die wir glaube ich alle in unserem persönlichen Umkreis weiterverfolgen, die alle was mit einem kollaborativen Potenzial zu tun haben. Deswegen würde ich auch nochmal sagen, ich glaube schon, dass es eventuell eine Bedrohungssituation oder sowas gibt. Also ich meine, gerade wenn man sich so die weltpolitische Struktur im Moment anguckt, gibt es ja schon viele Sachen, die einen eventuell beunruhigen können und die auch dazu führen können, dass man sich vielleicht außerhalb von einem sicheren Raum zusammentut und sagt, wir wollen jetzt irgendwie was verändern. Und ich glaube, das sind alles kleine Projekte, wo jeder vor sich dran arbeitet und was quasi das große angeht, wo There is no Game hingehen kann oder wo quasi das hingehen kann, was am Kongress angefangen hat, das sind wir eigentlich noch so ein bisschen dran zu finden.
Es gehört, There is no Game gehört allen, deswegen können wir dazu nicht viel sagen hier.
Und ich würde eben auch nochmal auf diese Idee von gesellschaftlicher Relevanz eingehen, dass das für mich auch nicht immer damit zu tun hat, dass man einen Big Impact macht, wo man, also wir haben ja schon mal tausend Leute irgendwie erreicht, das ist schon mal ziemlich okay viel für so was. Für ein halbes Jahr nicht schlafen, finde ich ganz okay. Es geht aber auch nicht darum, dass wir jetzt kommen und von oben eben wieder was bringen, wieder eine Struktur aufbauen oder dass wir quasi eine Utopie vorgeben, nach der dann gehandelt werden soll, sondern vielmehr, dass wir jetzt quasi Tools an die Hand gegeben haben, mit denen Utopien von unten gebaut werden können. Und das fängt für mich eben im Kleinen an, eben dass man dieses Bewusstsein hat, ich kann mit anderen Menschen interagieren, ich weiß, was ich kann, was ich nicht kann. Und schon nur damit umgehen zu können, das strukturieren zu können. Und dass sich das halt kulturelles Memenartig ja auch weiter verbreiten kann. Also daher auch die Idee mit einer eigenen Sprache. Wir haben einfach einige neue Wörter angefangen mit der Idee, dass wir halt Worte brauchen, die das ausdrücken können, wofür es in unseren gegenwärtigen Sprachen noch keine Worte gibt. Oder Worte zu haben, die was ausdrücken, was wir unbedingt ausdrücken müssen. Oder die ein Bild von einem Leben abbilden, das wir haben könnten. Weil Worte ja immer ausmachen, wie wir denken. Sprache strukturiert unser Denken und somit unser Handeln. Und um quasi gegen diese Ideologie auch anzukommen, brauchen wir auch neue Worte und eine neue Sprache. Ein Beispiel dafür ist oder quasi auch eines der Kernworte ist Thale, worauf sich dann auch der Name thale.net ergeben hat. Und Thale bedeutet übersetzt, zu denken ist zu teilen, zu teilen ist zu helfen, zu helfen ist zu wissen. Also diese Triade von Denken, Helfen, Wissen und Teilen. Das ist keine Triade, das sind vier. Richtig gut, Miku. Hätte auch niemand gemerkt, wenn ich nicht gesagt hätte, Schatz. Also eigentlich geht es darum, dass Thalen bedeutet, sowohl Denken als auch Helfen als auch Teilen als auch Wissen. Aus dieser Idee heraus, dass Information frei sein muss und dass wir uns gegenseitig alle Informationen zukommen lassen müssen, um gemeinsam als Gemeinschaft, als Community weiterzukommen. Das ist die Idee hinter dem Wort Thale. Und in diesem Sinne eben ein Ausdruck für etwas, wofür es noch keinen konkreten Ausdruck gibt, aber wo quasi ein Bild von etwas übertragen wird, das sich auch weiter verbreiten kann. Und wenn man diese Worte dann weiter benutzt, dann breiten die sich aus. Und genauso denke ich, ist es eben, was den Impact von There is no Game anbelangt. Wenn man dann dieses Wissen, dass man diese Erfahrung, die man gemacht hat, weiter verbreitet, dann breitet die sich auch aus.
Ich würde gerne zu dem, dieser Frage, ob wir außerhalb des Kongresses oder solcher Combat Zones agieren wollen oder sollten noch mal was sagen, weil natürlich wollen wir das. Und natürlich wissen wir, dass wir da uns ins gemachte Nest setzen, auf eine Art. Und gleichzeitig ist die Frage, ist es unsere Aufgabe, die ganze Welt top down von unserer Utopie zu überzeugen und hinzugehen und allen Muggels beizubringen, dass sie irgendwie jetzt miteinander reden können und interagieren können und am Hauptbahnhof stehen bleiben und drei Züge verpassen, weil sie super spannend finden, sich auszutauschen. Ist es nicht bei allen und natürlich ist aber unsere Aufgabe, da rauszugehen. Und wir haben jetzt eben zwei Tage hier in Berlin zusammengesessen und überlegt, für uns als Spieleberatungs-Konglomerat, also weniger There is no Game, weil das eben so viele sind, sondern uns drei, die wir das als unseren Haupt... Also das ist einfach unser Beruf. Das machen wir die ganze Zeit. Wir sind mit nichts anderem beschäftigt. Wo können wir da hingehen? Und es gibt unterschiedliche Methoden. Natürlich gibt es Methoden von Kulturförderung, von Kunsträume nutzen, um da raus wirksam zu sein. Es gibt aber auch die Überlegung, wie können wir das nennen, um Social Entrepreneurship, wie auch immer so Bereiche auszunutzen, reinzugehen, um überhaupt irgendwo anders stattzufinden als in Communities, die uns mit offenen Armen empfangen, weil sie sowieso die Idee geil finden. Und da ist am Ende auch wieder noch eine Idee von, wir brauchen auch Kollaboration, wir brauchen auch Ermächtigung. Also wenn Leute Ideen haben, wo wir das wie machen können oder uns darin unterstützen können, dass wir in für uns auch gefährlicheren Räumen stattfinden können, dann kommt zu uns, wir wollen das. Wir wollen nichts anderes tun als an dieser Substanz weiterarbeiten. Und wir wollen das nicht nur in unseren eigenen Schutzräumen machen.
Ich kriege es auch nicht ganz zusammen. Weil einerseits sagt ihr, also am liebsten würden wir uns abschaffen, aber andererseits wollt ihr sozusagen genau an der Substanz weiterarbeiten.
Ja, das ist die große Krux. Das ist ja auch genau das Problem. Warum sitzen wir hier? Das ist auch so, ja, nicht die 50 anderen oder nicht die 1000 Nichtspielenden so. Und ich glaube, dass aber, was wir können, was eine Fähigkeit ist, ich glaube nicht, wir haben heute Mittag gesagt, normalerweise spricht man immer davon, dass man in eine Saat setzt und dann die Leute, dann wächst das, bla bla, dass diese Metapher, unsere Metapher ist, wir graben das Betum, damit die Leute dann sich ihre Samen setzen können und selbst entscheiden, was da wachsen soll.
Ich glaube, das Paradox darin ist irgendwie, dass diese Struktur gleichzeitig inhaltlich auch unsere Utopie ist auf eine Art. Und natürlich, wir das auch überhaupt nicht mehr auseinanderhalten können und wir teilweise eben auch, als wenn wir dann so zu dritt zusammensitzen, Miko ist dann einfach unsere Propagandaministerin, weil die die ganze Zeit sitzt und Texte schreibt. Wir uns gegenseitig natürlich auch total versuchen, auf die Schippe zu nehmen, damit, dass wir da am Reißbrett Dinge planen. Natürlich geht das irgendwie nicht auf. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber auch die Frage so, was sollen wir jetzt machen? Sollen wir jetzt alle gar nichts mehr machen, damit keiner was macht, was hier mit jemandem anders gemacht wird? Also ich mein, mir ist es lieber, dass alle sich ermächtigt fühlen und etwas tun und darin eine Auseinandersetzung stattfindet und da Sachen irgendwie auch abgebrochen werden oder da Leute sagen, okay, das finde ich richtig scheiße, ihr hört jetzt sofort auf damit. Und die Sachen, die alle richtig gut finden, gehen weiter. Und dann kann man trotzdem mal sagen, das fanden jetzt alle richtig lange richtig gut, lass mal kurz aufhören, weil vielleicht wird es unheimlich oder so und dann gucken, wie es weitergeht. Und es gibt keinen Rezept, wie wir damit umgehen, aber erstmal ist sozusagen die Füße stillhalten und nichts tun, um nicht irgendjemandem anders irgendwas zu sagen, was vielleicht irgendwie in einer Richtung passiert oder so, ist keine Option.
Ja, und ich glaube, was halt wichtig ist, wir nehmen ja auch quasi uns zwar gern mal auf die Schippe, aber alle anderen Menschen, mit denen wir es zu tun haben, nehmen wir total ernst und ich glaube, das ist wichtig. Und ich glaube, in dieser Ernsthaftigkeit liegt ja dann auch, dass wir die Leute so ernst nehmen und hinzutrauen, dass wenn wir ihnen eine Utopie vorsetzen, die sie total scheiße finden, dass sie dann auch sagen, das ist totaler Bullshit, was ihr da macht. Und dann sind wir natürlich bereit, uns da drauf auch einzulassen und zu sagen, ja stimmt, oh je, was haben wir denn da uns ausgedacht. Also ich glaube, wir versuchen immer ein Angebot zu machen und gehen davon aus, dass alle Menschen um uns herum total schlau sind und das auch entweder mitmachen, weil sie es gut finden oder halt das reflektieren. Also ich glaube, das ist total wichtig, auch am Ansatz, dass quasi, ja, wir alle Menschen ernst nehmen und glauben, dass sie eine eigene Meinung dazu haben, zu dem, was wir machen.
Wow, ich glaube dafür brauchen wir schon die Jesus-Qualitäten. Aber gut, Marcus, ich wollte dich tatsächlich mal fragen, also du heute hier als Quoten-Mann und Quoten-Elektro-Hacker. Wie ist das denn für dich eigentlich sozusagen, also diesem Ding mitzuarbeiten, in diesem sozusagen auch riesigen Kontext, in dem das stattfinden kann, slash soll? Hast du jetzt dafür die Technik gebaut und tut es auch gut so oder bleibt man da inhaltlich involviert?
Ja, natürlich. Also was ich vorhin schon mal gesagt habe, wir interessieren uns ja alle für das selbe Thema, wir kommen nur aus unterschiedlichen Richtungen. Und natürlich hat dann jeder so sein Department, sagen wir jetzt so bei Mikko die Sprache oder die Storyline oder die Dramaturgie. Und jetzt bei mir sozusagen die Technik oder sozusagen beim, das hab ich natürlich nicht alleine gemacht, da waren natürlich ganz viele Leute mit dabei. Aber natürlich auch immer Input geben in Spielmechaniken, Ideen und so weiter. Also das ist jetzt nicht stumpf, du bist der Quoten-Nerd und darfst jetzt die Witze um die hin und her schieben. Das war natürlich immer ein Ping-Pong-Spiel.
Es gab diesen schönen Anruf, wo ich irgendwann mal angerufen hab in der Rauffahrt. Irgendwie so, Markus, wir brauchen Updates, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, was abgeht bei euch. Schieb mal was rüber, erzähl mal, was live passiert. Und irgendwie so zurück kamen, wie Update, unser Workpackage ist dort definiert, Delivery ist nächste Woche und wir so, ah, was bedeuten diese Worte? Das ist doch alles live. Also das und trotzdem finde ich aber auch nochmal spannend, dass diese Idee von Partizipation sich technisch abgebildet hat, weil es eine Dokumentation darüber gab, die natürlich auch total schwierig war, weil was da zukommt ist, wir hatten natürlich total Angst, dass wir einfach sofort, dass sofort alles lahmgelegt wird. Wenn wir mit irgendeiner Technik da ankommen, war die ganze Zeit so, was für eine Scheiße, macht das Sinn, dass wir USB-Schlüssel benutzen?
Aber ist das passiert? Ne, also die Technik lief, wir wurden nicht irgendwie böse gehabt und hat auch keiner irgendwie böse Dinge getan. Also wenn dann auf so einer Metaebene oder was sozusagen als Teil der Dramaturgie auch gewünscht war, ist natürlich passiert. Jetzt aber uns ist nichts aufgemacht worden, zumindest bis jetzt. Wir haben nichts mitgekriegt. Ne, genau. Lief alles.
Das Kaugummi im Schlüsselloch, was ich immer so für dich gesteht hab, gab's noch nicht?
Also wir hatten natürlich Probleme, ganz klar. Also ein paar Vereinszette, dass mal Technik ausgefallen ist, dass ein USB-Key abgebrochen ist. Aber alles Dinge, die halt im Rahmen sind.
Klingt jetzt so super entspannt. Das war so per Funk so, wo ist die Person mit der Pinzette? Ein Schlüsselloch 37 ist in Stick stecken geblieben, sofort dahin. Aber ich finde tatsächlich, möchte nochmal da auch dir, Max und auch Clemens, der jetzt nicht hier ist, mit dem du ja immer maßgeblich zusammengearbeitet hast, auch...
Dann sag mal noch Ro bitte, weil...
Genau, und Ro, der diese Keyholds entwickelt hat, mehr Leute in der Raumfahrtagentur usw. Genau, gar nicht erst Anfang namen zu nennen, sonst misskommen alle. Und alle anderen. Aber diese technische Grundlage, die da war, die war schon einfach extrem geil. Und die war, glaub ich, auch für viele Leute da einfach ein extremer Flash, weil Marcus kam an und hat diese Software Toto mitgebracht. Und wir haben gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall hat da jemand ein Smartphone in der Hand. Und in dieser Gruppe, als wir da saßen, gesagt haben, wir wollen irgendetwas anderes, was kein Smartphone ist, ist dann, genau, immer wieder haben wir so mitgekriegt, ist dann entstanden, dass es eben diese Keyholds gibt, die alle, die wo wir dann früh dem Deko-Team vom Kongress gesagt haben, so und so sind die Maße überlegt, wo das stattfinden kann, wo ihr das einbauen könnt. Dann gab es die sogenannten Aktoren, was x-beliebe Geräte sein können, die von der Spielsoftware angesteuert werden und bestimmte Texte, Videos, Informationen. Die Aktenvernichterin war mein Lieblingsaktor. Also sozusagen nochmal andere Geräte, die auch von dieser Software getriggert wurden. Das heißt, auf der technischen...
Die Nichtspieler hatten diese USB-Sticks und konnten sie in USB-Slots einpassen. Und tatsächlich schließen auch.
Tatsächlich schließen.
Und dann sozusagen wurden da Dinge aktiviert.
Und dann konntest du auf dem... Das Keyhole hat erkannt, welche Bande gerade ankommt. Und dann konntest du ein Passwort eingeben. Wenn es richtig war, ist auf dem Display der nächste Hint erschienen. Und zum Beispiel über dir die Aktenvernichterin losgegangen. Dann stand auf dem Keyhole Information on Paper. Und du hattest sehr viele Papierschnipsel um dich rumliegen. Und musstest sie zusammensetzen.
Gibt es den Kram, jetzt kann man den benutzen? Also quasi diese ganze...
Es gibt diese ganzen Keyholes, die stehen hier in Berlin im Lager.
Genau, die stehen jetzt gerade im Lager und werden hoffentlich zur Schar oder so wieder rausgeholt. Weiß ich nicht. Aber im Prinzip ja.
Es ist auch eine Frage, mit der wir... Im Prinzip sollen die natürlich benutzt werden und im Idealfall auch nicht nur von uns. Das sind die Aufgaben, vor denen wir stehen. Die sind hier und die sollen da nicht verrotten. Die sollen aber nur für kollaborative Prozesse benutzen.
Ist das dieses Tale-Netzwerk, wo man quasi selber seine Queste...
Kein kurzer Kenntnis. Die Software ist eine Game Engine. Es ist eigentlich so, man kann da Leute... Also Spiele-Designer können online im Browser ihren Spiele-Content eingeben, können Bilder hochladen, den ganzen Kram. Und der Endbenutzer spielt das im Wesentlichen mit einem Smartphone. Was Katja schon sagte, wir wollten keine Smartphones. Deshalb haben wir jetzt sozusagen als besondere Spielmechanik oder Special Casing, sozusagen auch Customization, diese Keyholds gebaut. Und damit haben sozusagen, das war sozusagen das User-Interface, sozusagen die Schnittstelle für den User zum System.
Also die Software leistet quasi, dass ihr das Sortieren der Spiele sozusagen verwalten könnt. Und dann gibt es einen Trigger, der immer einen Schritt weitergeht. Das kann das Smartphone sein, aber es kann auch das USB-Ding sein. Das kann auch etwas anderes ausdenken. Die Sendung ist ja jetzt schon bald vorbei. Ich würde euch ganz kurz noch, vielleicht schaffen wir drei Runden, und fragen wollen, das erste ist, gibt es jetzt irgendein Thema von There is no Game, das wir nicht gesprochen haben, was wir jetzt auch nicht mehr machen können, aber was ihr wenigstens, wo ihr quasi die Headline sagen könnt, okay, das haben wir eigentlich vergessen, da müsste man vielleicht nochmal drüber reden.
Leidenschaft ist ganz wichtig. If you trust in the dedication of others, you empower yourself to follow yours.
Das hört sich mal ein sehr schöner Kalenderspruch an. Da sind wir gut drin.
Was gefehlt hat? Ich könnte mich natürlich unendlich lange über die ganzen technischen Aspekte und so weiter unterhalten.
Was ich mich auch gefragt habe ist, wir haben jetzt ganz viel über den großen Kontext geredet und das Umfeld und das Ding. Ich würde von euch gerne, als ihr da schon irgendwie dabei wart, eine konkrete einzelne Szene, einen Moment, wo ihr dachtest, das ist nicht so einfach, das ist halt so super, das ist das, was ich gehofft hatte, was man da leben kann. Gab es einen Moment, der euch noch ganz deutlich in Erinnerung ist, der schön war?
Also ich fand, als ich gehört habe, dass die Leute angefangen haben, Wiki-Seiten anzulegen und Pads zu schreiben, weil das war genau das, was wir erreichen wollten, nämlich, dass die Leute zusammenarbeiten und plötzlich bauen die halt wirklich lange Wiki-Seiten, wo die ihre Ergebnisse sharen, miteinander teilen und so weiter. Und das war so ein bisschen die Belohnung für die Arbeit, weil das genau das war, was wir erreichen wollten.
Ich hätte auch noch was beizutragen, genau. Also ich war quasi mal wieder auf dem Weg zu einem Keyhole, wo ein USB-Stick stecken geblieben war mit der Pinzette. Und bin quasi da die Treppe, da wo es auch zum Himmel geht, hochgelaufen. Und dann stand da so eine Riesengruppe von Leuten, die ich dann als Bande identifiziert hab. Und dann hab ich so geguckt, was machen die denn da? Und dann war eine von den NPCs bei denen und hat denen das Ting-Lied beigebracht. Und die gesamte Gruppe hat dieses Lied gesungen. Und das fand ich mega cool. Weil natürlich alle Leute, die vorbeigelaufen sind, geguckt haben, warum singen diese ganzen Leute? Was ist da los? Und ich dachte mir so, wie schön. Also es war irgendwie so ein toller Moment, weil man gemerkt hat, das greift so. Die Leute haben sich in relativ öffentlichen Raum gestellt und einfach zusammen gesungen und hatten echt Spaß dran.
Ich möchte tatsächlich eine Erfahrung, die ich nicht miterlebt habe, aber immer wieder erzählt bekommen habe von Clemens Teilen. Und zwar gab es so einen Bombenkoffer, der an Tag 3 oder Tag 4, glaube ich, rausgekommen ist, der mit so einem Armband funktionierte. Da ist ein Countdown abgelaufen. Und wenn man das Armband vom Handgelenk abgemacht hat, ist der Countdown schneller abgelaufen. Und Clemens erzählt immer wieder von der Situation, dass er in einer Lounge war, wo es diesen Brunnen gab, der für viele Sachen so Zentrum war. Und irgendwie so 30 Leute reingerannt kamen in die Lounge, geschrien haben, haut ab vom Brunnen, wir müssen sofort an den Brunnen mit diesem Koffer in der Hand, wo so die letzten Sekunden abliefen. Genau, das erzählt er immer wieder, ist ein ganz tolles Bild von Bewegungen auch. Sehr schön.
Ja, eine meiner Lieblingsszenen ist Tag 2, es ist 12.30 Uhr und wir hatten am Ende von Tag 1 so ein Schild aufgestellt, dass wir um 12.30 Uhr am nächsten Tag wieder zurück sind. Und wir haben es natürlich nicht geschafft, pünktlich anzufangen. Ist ja auch schwierig. Und einfach diese Traube an Leuten, die schon da standen und darauf gewartet haben, dass es wieder losgeht. Und in dem Moment war ich natürlich einfach nur gestresst. Aber jetzt so in hindsight ist es einfach so, wow. Also, dass die Leute einfach so eagle sind, endlich wieder weitermachen zu können. Das war schon richtig cool.
Und die greifsten Nichtspielenden, die man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann, gewesen auf jeden Fall.
Und dann würde ich noch gerne wissen, was was ist, womit ihr wohl im Vorhinein vielleicht gedacht habt, das wird auf jeden Fall passieren, was dann nicht eingetreten ist. Dinge, die überraschenderweise völlig anders waren als geplant.
Also die Piemaldam-Quest, das hat glaube ich nie funktioniert, die wir vorhin schon erzählt haben mit dem Winkelmesser.
Die Bleistiftmarkierung gibt es immer noch.
Die Bleistiftmarkierung ist eventuell noch um CCH.
Wenn es noch steht.
Wir gucken mal nach der Renovation.
Was haben wir noch? Was nicht? Das ist schwierig.
Ja, das Kaugummi. Also ich war fest davon überzeugt, dass irgendjemand ein Kaugummi in eins von den Keyholes reinsteckt. So einfach, um das auszutesten, ist aber auch nicht passiert.
Es sind erstaunlich viele Dinge passiert, die wir uns erhofft haben, dass sie passieren. Und noch mehr, wie so diese Wiki-Seite und so. Es gab tatsächlich so eine Art End-Quest am Ende, die damit zu tun hatte, dass eine präparierte Wohnung eingebrochen werden musste. Da sind Leute nicht auf die Art und Weise reingekommen, wie es der Plan war. Nämlich über einen Freifunkknoten vom CCH aus sollte jemand die Tür öffnen. Die haben dann irgendwie 2, 5 Stunden das Türschloss noch aufgemacht und waren noch Pizza essen, um sich zu beraten. Und da gibt es aber, glaube ich, auch tolle Aufnahmen. Weil da Sandra, hoffentlich die Dokofilmerin, dabei war. Das ist anders verlaufen. Aber es sind ansonsten...
Wir wussten ja auch eigentlich gar nicht, was passiert. Also das war ja auch so ein bisschen das mit diesem Reisbrett. Wir haben immer gedacht, okay, wir stellen uns das jetzt so und so vielleicht vor. Aber passiert das so und passiert das so? Also ich glaube, wir waren einfach von super vielen Sachen auch total, also eigentlich immer positiv überrascht.
Ja, am Ende haben wir natürlich die ganzen kleinen Schritte ganz wenig mitbekommen, die wir teil... Also es gab Leute, die viel mit uns zusammen auch ihre Quest entwickelt haben. Es gab auch Leute, die einfach was gemacht haben, wo wir gar nicht wussten, was da passiert. Das heißt, wir haben natürlich unseren größeren narrativen Bogen mitbekommen und erlebt und der war auch auf eine Art so gestrickt, dass wir, was wir halt ganz gut können, sozusagen live reagieren konnten auch mit Dingen. Was da im Kleinen überall passiert sind und was ich noch viel spannender finde, wie viele Dinge passiert sind, die nicht dazugehörten, aber in Augen der Spielenden, nicht Spielenden dazugehörten. Nobody knows, glaub ich.
Wann hattet ihr zum ersten Mal den Moment, wo ihr so gedacht habt, die haben begriffen, worum es hier geht?
Doch, ich erinnere mich an so einen Moment, wo wir hinten so standen und so geschrien haben. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war, aber es war so dieses... Ich glaube, als wir in unserem Backoffice im Monitoring gesehen haben, dass irgendjemand das erste Passwort eingegeben hat. Aber es war...
Ich glaube, es war ein Moment, als die ersten zwei Banden fusioniert haben. Das war auch ein großer Moment.
Es ist eine Fusion, dann sind wir losgerannt oder mit diesen Kinderfahrrädern dahin gefahren. Aber tatsächlich, die Wiki-Seite war echt zum Heulen, als wir die gefunden haben, dieser Anfangstext. Und das hat uns unsere Erwartungen maßlos übertroffen.
Wenn man jetzt, was auch immer passieren wird, weiterformuliert, wo macht man das?
Es gibt die E-Mail-Adresse Join, There is no Game, die wir haben, die wir drei bekommen. Vier, paar Leute von uns hängen in diesen Postfach rum. Es gibt einen Twitter-Account. Wer heißt der?
Add is no Game.
Wir sind irgendwie so hier und es gibt auch mittlerweile viele Leute, die irgendwie uns erreichen können und arbeiten daran, dass wir mit der Spieleberatung auftauchen. Wir hatten dafür noch keine Zeit bisher seit zwei Jahren.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was noch passieren wird. Miko, Katja, Sarah und Markus, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Im Chaosradio 2032, das entgegen anlasslautender Ankündigung doch stattgefunden hat. Vielen Dank auch an vor allen Dingen Peter, Mo und Helena, die zum Gelingen dieser Sendung beigetragen haben. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.